[Music]
new tonight another report of a stolen
car from a valet on the strip this comes
after we first shared the story of a
woman whose car went missing after
dropping it off victoria saha is live on
this story joining us live near the
paris hotel with a bit more victoria
brian for those of us who don't want to
use a self parking garage you might
think that using a valet is a better
option but now a woman says her car was
stolen from the paris hotel valet now
this is a second person reaching out to
us
with a busy city like las vegas hundreds
of thousands of people find their way
here many flying in but also many opting
to drive which means parking on the
strip but now we're learning it could
come with some risks last week we told
you the story about a woman whose range
rover was stolen from the valley at
paris hotel after someone found her
ticket then katie francis reached out
saying the same thing happened to her
months before when you saw our story
that we did a few weeks ago with a
similar situation what were your
thoughts
i was pissed because just to hear that
it's continuing to happen to people and
they're not doing anything francis used
the valet at the paris on march 23rd for
just an hour when she came out she
couldn't find her ticket so they're like
oh no problem your car's on the way up
you just need to fill out this paperwork
but while she was filling out her form
francis sees a woman get into her car
and drive away
you knew the ticket was gone we had
already filled out the paperwork
and yet you still just decided to have
this lady our keys francis says she was
told that woman handed them this valet
ticket and that is how she was able to
drive away with her car no questions
asked francis's car was missing for 10
days and when she got it back it was
trashed with multiple different license
plates found inside and she was told two
arrests were made
francis says the valley of paris didn't
give her any answers as to how this
happened so i called them and they said
they did practice standard protocol but
they don't require to check id when
returning a car to a customer the
manager at the valley of harris said
that they pride themselves in doing a
good job victoria zaha live local now